ah
[Música]
i
el expresidente de martín vizcarra la ex
ministra de salud pilar mazzetti y la ex
canciller elizabeth astete encabezan la
lista de 101 funcionarios públicos sus
familiares y otros relacionados que
fueron vacunados clandestinamente
fernando carbone quien dirige la
comisión investigadora del gobierno
peruano sobre la escándalo conocido como
el vacuna gate reveló que 470 personas
recibieron la dosis candidata a la
vacuna de laboratorio chino sino farc
trescientos sesenta y nueve de ellas
pertenecen al grupo de profesionales en
el ensayo clínico mientras que más de
100 fueron inmunizadas y regularmente el
presidente de vizcarra y las ex
ministras masetti astete están siendo
investigadas por la fiscalía y el
congreso y el resto de funcionarios
también serán procesados tras ser
separado de sus cargos sobre el vacuna
gate fernando carbone ha dicho que si no
farm ha ofrecido dosis adicionales de su
vacuna anti cobit en países de oriente
medio y asia al respecto algunos medios
locales advierten que china habría
alentado una vacunación a funcionarios
peruanos como estrategia de marketing
para sacar ventaja a sus competidores
[Música]
el escándalo de las vacunas vip las
vacunas recibidas por gente no
prioritaria o que se saltó la fila entre
ellos funcionarios periodistas y
empresarios fue un simbronazo en medio
de la pandemia en argentina llevó a la
renuncia y reemplazo del ministro de
salud y forzó al gobierno a dar
explicaciones y modificar la forma en
que funcionarios públicos podrán ser
considerados estratégicos y recibir la
vacuna además la justicia está
investigando lo ocurrido pero el de las
vacunas vip no fue el único escándalo
hubo casos en que desaparecieron dosis
de vacuna torios y otros en los que se
debieron descartar vacunas porque no se
mantuvo la cadena de frío e incluso
antes del escándalo de las vacunas vip
que fue responsabilidad del gobierno
nacional se conocieron varios casos de
personas no priorizadas que habían sido
vacunadas en diferentes provincias del
país es que la vacunación está
descentralizada en argentina y la mayor
parte la realiza en las provincias y no
la nación y así que aunque la nación
haya implementado vías menos vagas para
decidir a quién vacunar ya quién no nada
quita que sigan apareciendo escándalos a
nivel local
[Música]
a un año del primer caso positivo de
kobe 19 en ecuador la corrupción ha sido
la característica de la pandemia en el
país andino la renuncia del ministro de
salud juan carlos ceballos es el caso
que más ha indignado la opinión pública
el 26 de febrero reconoció que vacuno en
primer lugar a su mamá que vive en uno
de los geriátricos privados más
exclusivos del país no ha priorizado una
lista de 96 hospitales públicos se les
responsabiliza de una supuesta lista de
vacunación y haití invitaciones a
personas fuera de la primera línea
emergencia y denuncias de mal manejo de
la pandemia las fuertes presiones a su
gestión terminaron con su salida del
país hacia los eeuu y la eliminación de
sus cuentas en la red social 'twitter'
al día siguiente de conocerse su carta
de renuncia al exministro de saleh
criticó por su falta de transparencia en
el plan de vacunación deja pendiente un
juicio político en la asamblea nacional
y una investigación penal en su contra
pero días antes el ex funcionario había
asegurado que no contarán con él para
salir por la puerta de atrás
[Música]